- [Narrator] Okay, so here
are three rules to live by
that will quickly improve your life.
Rule number one, follow the
path of most resistance.
Now, this obviously
isn't an absolute rule,
like you probably have a lot of resistance
towards driving into oncoming traffic
or throwing your laptop into a lake,
and that's probably a good thing.
But if you have two brain
cells to rub together,
then you probably know
that's not what I'm talking about here.
I'm talking about the
internal resistance you feel
when you think about doing
something constructive,
something that would
move your life forward
in some way or another,
like writing a cover letter
for a job posting you've
been keeping an eye on,
or finally cleaning your
hell hole of a garage
where you've been stashing
eight months of cardboard.
This type of internal
resistance that you feel
when you think about
taking care of these things
is also the same type of resistance
that feels empowering to overcome,
but paralyzing if we stay under its thumb.
But if we can learn to not
shy away from this feeling,
but instead lean into it,
we will find that our
life will rapidly improve
because the most rewarding things in life
are hidden behind discomfort
or resistance paywalls.
We purchase long-lasting
order and success in our lives
through temporary discomfort,
and if we become aware of
this weird little transaction
that seems to be deeply woven
into the fabric of reality,
we can use it to our advantage.
We can be comfortable
with making this trade
as often as possible.
And one thing that I've noticed
is that as we get better
at willingly leaning into
this discomfort of action,
after a while,
we'll actually start to enjoy
the feeling of resistance.
It's kind of a weird thing.
The discomfort itself becomes
exciting and empowering.
I think this is because
since resistance is a source
of power after we transcend it,
then once we go through this process
of transcending it frequently enough,
our brain eventually starts to clue in.
We'll just link this feeling
of discomfort with empowerment,
and we'll get excited to overcome
obstacles and challenges.
Remember this rule.
When we overcome resistance,
we absorb its power.
The greater the resistance,
the greater the power.
Rule number two, don't
stop doing the things
that got you out of a bad situation.
Kind of a mouthful.
But what I mean is that human beings
are pretty hilarious sometimes.
It's because most of
the time we know exactly
what we need to do to
stop feeling like crap,
like if we've worked
ourselves into a hole,
we're playing more video
games, we're eating junk food,
blabbity blabbity blah,
and we're just not
taking care of ourselves,
we're in this negative mindset,
this self-loathing spiral.
Eventually this goes on for
a long enough period of time
that we eventually snap.
We say, "You know what?
I'm tired of living my
life like a piece of crap.
I'm gonna change things up."
So we bounce back.
We start eating better,
we start going to the gym,
we start getting our work done on time,
and we start showering in the morning
and dressing into something half decent.
And as we do this, we start
to feel better and better.
We start to feel more confident,
we start to feel more energized
and better about ourselves.
But the weird thing is
something usually happens.
Since we no longer have
that negative incentive
to work ourselves out of the hole,
we kind of forget why we
were taking care of ourselves
to begin with.
So we start to slip.
We cut corners.
We skip the gym one day.
That turns into two days,
which turns into a week,
into a month,
and we eventually slip and
slide down the slippery
and slidey slope back into the hole
from whence we came.
But have you ever considered
what your life might look like
if you didn't stop doing the things
that got you out of a bad situation?
Because in reality, there's
no secret to success.
Success isn't built by doing
lavish, extraordinary things
like banging out an entire book overnight,
200 brilliant pages of literature,
and it's not by going to the
gym harder than everyone else
that one time you're
motivated to go to the gym.
You work out so hard that
one day you just explode
into this meat mountain.
No, it's ridiculous.
Success is built by doing the same things
that got us out of our rut,
but just continuing to
do those same things
every single day, over
a long period of time.
The key is to just do
these things long enough
that they get locked in as habits.
Habits, meaning that they're
easier to do than not to do,
because that's what
happens when you engage
with these things for long enough.
They'll eventually just
become a part of who you are
and they'll be easier
to do than not to do.
And if this sounds kind
of miserable to you,
just know that it doesn't
have to be such a grind
because as I've mentioned previously,
eventually doing these constructive things
feels really good.
On a long enough timeline,
you'll begin to look
forward to these things,
not as a means to an end,
but because of the way they make you feel.
So start small,
try to implement one simple habit
that you actually think
you're gonna stick to,
lock it in for 30 days
or however long it takes
until you feel like it's really sticking,
and then add a new habit.
And keep on doing that
until you're in a place
where you feel satisfied
with your daily life
and the activities that
you do on a daily basis.
That's different for everybody,
but use your judgment.
Okay, rule number three,
record everything.
So life can be pretty turbulent.
Some days, life really
just deals you a shit hand
and maybe something truly
devastating happens to you
and it rocks your world
and you have no idea what to do.
And other times you have an amazing day.
You feel euphoric, on top of the world.
You think to yourself, "Holy smokes.
Why don't I feel like this more often?"
Instead of remaining completely oblivious
as to why you feel good or bad,
why not start writing stuff down
and recording your thoughts and feelings
on a day-to-day basis?
Because when you do this,
patterns start to emerge.
You start to realize that
there's an intimate relationship
between your repeated behaviors
and the way that they make you feel.
So I truly believe one of
the best bang-for-buck habits
you can start implementing is
just recording your thoughts,
either as a voice memo
or as a written document
on a piece of paper or a notebook.
Because once we start verbalizing
or writing things down,
taking our thoughts
out of the weird
cobweb-ridden nest in our head
and manifesting them into the real world,
as woo-woo as that sounds,
it's easier to see our
thoughts for what they are.
And once our thoughts and
behaviors are actually recorded
in an objective way,
then it becomes really difficult
to keep making the same mistakes.
You'll start to eventually clue in that,
"Oh, when I do this, I feel like that.
When I think these types of thoughts,
it makes me feel like this."
And hypothetically, yeah,
I think you can come
to these conclusions without
writing these things down,
but why make this process of growing
as a person any slower
than it needs to be?
And no matter whether you're
recording your thoughts
and feelings from a good day or a bad day,
all information is good information.
Use this information to your benefit
and your life will dramatically improve.
So that's pretty much it.
These three rules have
really helped me in my life
and I really hope they help you as well.
I just wanna give a big
thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes,
covering dozens of topics.
I'm always blown away by
just how many inspiring
and insightful filmmaking
classes there are on there
that really helped me bring
my videos to the next level.
And maybe you're not into filmmaking,
maybe you're into photography or cooking,
or coding, or learning to play the piano.
No matter what you're into
or what you want to learn,
there's probably a class
for it on Skillshare.
And I always find that
classes on Skillshare
are extremely practical,
and that's because Skillshare
classes are designed
for real life.
It's super easy to take
whatever you're learning
on Skillshare and apply it directly
to your real life pursuits.
And Skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where the first 1000 of
you who click my link
in the description below will
get a one month free trial
of Skillshare Premium.
So make sure you take
advantage of that link,
learn something new,
explore your creativity,
and as usual, have a great time.
So if you liked this video,
make sure you actually hit the like button
because when you hit the like button,
the algorithm says, "Wow, this
video must be pretty good.
Let's recommend it to more people."
And that could potentially
help somebody out
if they're not having
such a good time in life.
And you know,
my video helps them get
out of a bad situation.
And let's not lie, that helps me out too.
It helps me do what I do
and continue to make YouTube videos.
And I like making these. It's fun.
Other than that, thank
you so much for watching.
Make sure to check out the second channel.
I've been a little bit
inactive on there recently
but exciting things
are coming in September
so make sure that you don't miss that.
Other than that, thank
you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.
- Exactly.
Do you understand me, Capo Wane?
- I understand you're loose.
(man cackling)